the atmosphere is a fascinating place
it's what I'm lucky enough to be
studying my PhD in fact and it
represents a whole bunch of different
academic pursuits coming together
physics chemistry computer science
geography maths even space science and
it affects us both locally in terms of
our weather but also on a planetary
scale when we look at global warming and
climate change and potentially the
future of our species in this short
series of videos I'm going to be
introducing you to the atmosphere giving
you a brief overview of what it is and
how it works now I'm going to be
concentrating specifically on the
stratosphere for some of these videos
because that's what my area of research
is but we're still going to look at the
physics of how the whole atmosphere
works and give you an idea of what is
happening right now over your head each
video will have sources and further
reading listed in the description should
you wish to take your understanding
further and if you ever have any
questions about the content of the video
please always feel free to leave a
comment in the comment section down
below or equally if you have any
feedback about these videos that's very
much appreciated the word atmosphere
comes from two Greek words Atmos meaning
vapor and Sparrow meaning sphere
it's the envelope of gas which surrounds
our planet trapped by our gravity and
extends from the surface up to actually
that's kind of a difficult question to
answer you see the atmosphere is just
defined by the presence of a gas and the
presence of a gas is a very loose
description the atmosphere gets thinner
and thinner the higher you go up and so
there has to be a cut-off point
arbitrarily where you say the space
begins because there just aren't enough
atmospheric atoms present to say that
there is a gas and a typical definition
for where this happens is at a hundred
kilometers above the surface this is
called the common line and as the
International definition of where space
begins but it's important to realize
that that's an arbitrary definition that
atmospheric atoms exists way beyond
hundred kilometers way out to 700
kilometers above the surface 100
kilometers is convenient knows well as
being a nice round number and will
contain all the dynamics that we're
talking about in this video the
atmosphere fulfills a whole bunch of
different purposes it keeps us warmer
than would otherwise be it protects us
from harmful radiation from the Sun
distributes water and heat across the
surface of the earth and you know lets
us breathe it
for such a complex system it's primarily
made of just two ingredients the
atmosphere is made of a whole bunch of
different elements but most of it is
just nitrogen and oxygen these two
elements account for 99 percent of the
volume of the atmosphere with most of
the remainder being argon the last few
hundredths of a percent are mostly
carbon dioxide with neon hydrogen helium
methane and Krypton all making guest
appearances it's also worth noting that
at any given time about a quarter a
percent of the atmospheres mass is water
vapor which goes some way to explaining
why the atmosphere looks so cloudy from
space notice that 99 percent of the
atmosphere is either n2 or Oh to the
stable molecular forms of nitrogen and
oxygen both of which have two atoms
apiece the fact that trace gases such as
ozone carbon dioxide and methane all
have more than two atoms each is very
significant I'm going to talk more about
that in future videos like onions like
odors the atmosphere is made of many
layers and these are layers which humans
have defined but have a physical Norma
arbitrary basis and most common way in
which we define these layers is to use
the temperature profile in the vertical
so seeing how temperatures change
without you here at the surface we're
very familiar with the idea that the
higher you go up the colder it gets this
is why Mountaineers who are climbing
Everest have to wear so many different
insulating layers instead of shorts and
flip-flops so we define the bottom layer
of the atmosphere below in which we live
to be where temperatures decrease with
altitude and we call this layer the
troposphere and the troposphere Council
about 70% of whole mass of the
atmosphere but it doesn't extend all
that far up temperatures decrease from
the surface up to about 10 kilometers
and altitude where they reach a minimum
of about minus 50 or 60 degrees Celsius
but here the atmosphere starts to do
something kind of strange temperatures
stay the same for a few kilometers and
then as you get higher they start to
increase and they increase up to a
maximum of about zero degrees Celsius at
50 kilometers or so in altitude and
beyond this point the temperature starts
decrease again as you go higher up now
that layer between 10 kilometers and 50
kilometers an altitude is what we call a
stratosphere and it accounts for almost
the entirety of the remaining mass of
the atmosphere above it you have the me
stretching from about 50 to about 80
kilometers and altitude and above the
mesosphere you have the thermosphere
beyond which the atmospheric density is
so low that you're basically in the
vacuum of space although it's worth
pointing out that the atmospheric
density is so low here that all it takes
is for a few atoms in the layer to be
ionized by solar radiation and the
temperature the average temperature of
the whole layer shoots up which is why
these graphs look a little bit strange
when we talk about the atmosphere well
most the time we mean is the troposphere
stratosphere and mesosphere and to be
honest a lot of the time what we really
mean is just the troposphere but in a
lot of these videos we're going to be
focusing specifically on the
stratosphere and examining what makes it
the way it is and its interactions with
the troposphere
after that we're then going to go on to
talk about global warming and the
physics behind geoengineering
deliberately changing the climate
counteract global warming in this video
we've looked at the size of the
atmosphere stretching from the surface
to about 100 kilometers in altitude the
composition of the atmosphere be mostly
nitrogen and oxygen with other trace
gases present and the layers in the
atmosphere the troposphere stratosphere
mesosphere and thermosphere next time
we're going to be looking at the
stratosphere in more detail and trying
to explain why exactly it is so
different from the troposphere thank you
for watching if you enjoyed this video
then please give it a like and consider
subscribing to this channel for more
educational content we see that our
displaced air parcel which is at the
same pressure as its surroundings is
cooler than its surroundings and so has
a higher density and basically read them
in detail and writing them up in
scientific language called ley Tech it's
a scientific typesetting language which
makes up with
it's going to be what I'll run theses it